Hey guys, and welcome to another 1hour
flipping challenge. Today I'm going to
be doing something I've actually been
wanting to do for a long time, and that
is flipping uh any items that are part
of the item sets and crafting category.
Uh so that's going to be stuff like uh
repairing barrows armor, combining sets,
uh creating serpentine, helms, whatever,
like anything that can be uh transformed
easily and uh sold on the Grand
Exchange. Uh, even decanting potions is
probably good. Um, but these are always
really profitable and I haven't actually
tried just doing that for an hour. So, I
have the items and crafting page open up
on GE Tracker, which is a sponsor of
mine. This particular part here is
extremely useful. Having access to all
this definitely has made me personally a
lot of money. Uh, so let's go ahead and
get started. 1 hour. Let's go. And I
have 50 mil. Uh, let's just examine that
quickly. Perfect. All right. So, let's
go. So, I'm going to start off by uh
looking at the first thing here. So, I
know this is going to be a Barrow's
repair. Uh I'll have to leave the Grand
Exchange for this, but that's not a huge
deal. Uh so, yeah, basically the
Gotham's Warspear Zero looks like it is
possibly selling for about 1.3 mil. Uh
so, I'll go ahead and just put an offer
in for maybe two of those.
1330. So, Guffins war spear
zero and put in there for 1350. and
we'll go for two. All right, so next up,
looking at the list, I'm not going to do
the malad addiction wards. I'm not going
to do this one cuz it's too slow. Now,
the Gthan's armor set looks really
profitable. Something I have enjoyed uh
a lot is combining uh Barrow's armor
sets. Uh so, all I have to do is go
ahead and uh look at all the pieces.
First, I'm just going to see how many of
these are traded. Uh quite a lot, so
that's good. Now, I'm going to have to
go to each individual
piece and put a buy offer in uh for each
one. Now, the buy limit on these guys
are 10, uh, which I'll happily do all of
them. That being said, that's going to
be about 40 mil to do that. Uh, and I
might not do all of them at once. I'll
maybe do five to begin with, just so I
have money left for other things as
well. All right, so to start off, I'm
going to try buying the Gunth's helm.
So, I'll try buying it for
1261. Maybe 12. Let's do 1271. And we'll
do five of these. Next up, we'll do
the Gthan's chain skirt, uh, which I'll
try buying for 641. Next up is the
Gothin plate body, which seems to be
pretty close to 415. So, we'll do 415k
and five of those. Just kind of rough
estimates. If they don't come through,
I'll end up just changing the offers
around. And last up is going to be the
Gthan's Warspear, which is the most
expensive. And, uh, we're doing a couple
flips regarding this item. And looks
like
1780 and
1764. And we'll do five of these. All
right. So, looks good. We actually have
a couple of each item coming through
already. That's a good sign. It means
that we've gotten the price correct. And
then we're didn't insta buy it, which
isn't ideal, but we are actually buying
some to sell, which is great. So, since
I have one of each item, I'll go ahead
and create my first set. Gotham's armor
set. Perfect. Now, let's go see how much
I can sell it for. And I can calculate
the overall profit on this item. Selling
for 4187 it looks like. Got onto the day
graph and wow, this item is
tanking. It has just been on a very
perfectly straight direct downward
trend, but that's okay. Uh sell it for
uh
85. So it looks like on each uh set
combination I'll be making 87 if I sell
it for that price. Uh which is still
pretty good. on 10 combinations, that'll
be
870k, which is great. Okay, we already
sold off the set for 4187. That's good.
Uh, now it looks like I'm buying the
helms pretty quickly. Uh, but none of
the other items yet. We'll leave them a
little bit longer, though. Okay, so I
have managed to buy at least one more
set of the armor. Uh, we got all the
Gotham's helm coming through already,
which is good. And, uh, the next thing I
was looking at is actually the cannon
furnace. Uh, sorry, not the cannon
furnace, but the cannon set combination.
If we have a look on G Tracker, it looks
like 85k is a combination uh margin
right now, which is really good. Uh,
looks like all the pieces have dropped
pretty dramatically. Okay, so
interesting. I put all of the prices in
roughly around the same ratio of how
much above the average price I put it.
And this one instantly bought all of
them. And uh, we are slowly buying the
rest. Um, one of each. Perfect. That
means we have at least somewhat the
right price. Uh, so for whatever reason,
the price has tanked it pretty much
right now. Uh, it's maybe selling for
730. So, let's go ahead and calculate
that price. 71k on each set combination
for this is actually really good. Uh, so
I'll go ahead and pull all those out.
And it's perfect cuz I will have an
extra uh, G slot right now. Okay. So,
I'm going to start by selling off the
cannon pieces just because I do think
those are going to sell a bit quicker.
And uh we offer having enough offer
slots is a bit of an issue, but looks
like we combine two Gothan sets we can
do right now and uh two cannon sets as
well. Uh so we'll pop these cannon sets
in here to sell. Honestly, shouldn't
take too long. Sell them
for 731. How about that's actually a
really good price for a combination on a
item like this, which I've actually
never done before. All right. Like I
said, only took a couple minutes to sell
those off. So, I'm making 140k off those
two alone, which is really awesome. Now,
I'll go ahead and sell off these two.
Okay, I'm pulling this Gussens warper
offer out. Uh, it's just been so long. I
don't think that's actually going to be
coming through, which is fine. I didn't
This is kind of a hail Mary a little
bit. Okay, so I have bought all five of
the Guth armor set. Uh, which is
awesome. Uh, just going to collect those
all as items and that will be five of
those slips so far. So, we're getting
about what was it? 70k uh per flip. And
uh we've done it 70 70 to 80 anyway. And
I've done five of them so far. Uh so go
ahead and put an offer in for another
five of those. And we'll just hit the
buying limit for that. All right. So we
put another offer in for the plate
bodies and instantly bought them
hilariously enough uh for well we saved
5GP which is good. Uh Gthan's chain
skirts and the Goths war spears. Uh
going to put in for the same price. And
uh last up what do we got to buy?
Gthan's helms. Uh, we'll bump it up just
a couple to 1275 just in case we're kind
of on the brink of buying the item
again. Five of those. Are we going to
buy any more? No. But that's okay. Uh,
so I'm still getting 78k on each
combination, which is really good. Uh,
we sold off all the sets and bought all
the guts helms. So, we're just kind of
waiting on the other two. Uh, which is
fine. Now, for the cannon stands, we'll
collect and see how many we're at. Looks
like another three we can sell. Uh,
which we're getting 70 can each of
those. Pretty happy with that. Okay, we
actually insta sold them for 731. So, I
guess we'll bump it up a little more.
Now, one other good combination type
item is potion decanting. Uh, now I'm
going to be doing the prayer potion
because I only have about 30 minutes
left and that will be the quickest even
if it's not the most costefficient. Uh,
but we'll do 2k of these. Uh, since that
is a buying limit and you can make I
don't know, I'll probably make 120k off
that which isn't too bad. Okay, we have
a couple more sets we can combine as
well as another couple sold. That's
going to be another two Gothin sets and
another one sold, which is good. We're
pretty close to have flipped the entire
buy limit worth of them, which is pretty
nice. And the prayer potions are coming
through pretty consistently. And uh we
still have to buy some more cannon
bases, but after that, we can do a full
reset and um go ahead and buy some new
items. Okay, so I went ahead and put in
a new offer for the cannon base in two
bot, which is nice. And we have sold all
the Gotham's armor sets plus uh bought
all the rest of the pieces. So that's
nice. We'll finally have a lot more room
in our GE offer slots. And we can go
ahead and uh get a new item going. So
we'll combine the sets. That's going to
be another two. And that will be all 10
flipped. So that's 700k in total. 750k
probably. Uh we've made off of the
Gthins armor sets. Uh once all of these
guys buy, uh there will be another 70k
times 10. So 700k. So we're up to about
1.4 million profit roughly. Uh which is
really good. We're only about halfway
done now. I don't know if I'll be able
to successfully flip another full uh set
like that, but we'll give it a try. All
right, so here's the rocks helm, and it
looks like uh it's selling for about
300k. We'll try buying one of those. So,
rocks, helm zero, and we're looking to
buy it for 300 and somethingk. 305k and
we'll try two of these. I mean, worst
case scenario, I can always use that in
my set combination if I have to. And the
Gunth's armor sets have sold. So, that's
all of that sold. So, I have 750k on
that. Pretty happy with how that went.
Okay, all the prayer potions are done. I
bought 1994 of them. So, all I have to
do is run down here and uh decant with
Bob Barter. There we go. Pretty easy.
And then we just have to come back here
and just recheck the price. We're going
to sell them
for prayer potion
for. And we're going to sell them for
9550. And then from there, just pop them
in here
for 9550.
And so 14294 and we bought them for
14171. That's 120k profit. Not huge, but
really easy to do. All right, guys. So,
I did increase the price of the cannon
pieces a little bit, but there we go.
Everything has come through and we can
finally finish off this last set
combination. 21 minutes left. A little
awkward amount of time to finish this
in. Uh, but that's okay. We'll give it
our best shot. And all the prayer
potions have pretty well come through as
well. All right. Okay, so I'll pop the
remainder of those in there for
733. And they don't quite end the sale,
but that's fine. And all the prayer
potions have sold. Perfect. Now, I'll
have a go quick look at the item sets
and crafting page. Uh 20 minutes left
isn't a whole lot of time, but we could
still try to do the Verox armor set,
maybe. All right, last up. I'm going to
try the unholy book page set
combination. Uh, it's going to take a
while to sell, but the pages do buy
relatively
quickly. And the bind's only four, so
I'm only going to do like maybe two or
three of these. Uh, because there's only
20 minutes left. That's not a whole lot
of time. So, uh, we got three pages to
buy, 17 minutes, and everything else is
pretty well sold. I'm just going to pull
this out
because
Okay. Wow, that's pretty lucky. Okay.
Well, I'll go ahead and take this
opportunity to repair this in while I'm
waiting for these to buy. Okay, so I'm
just in Lumbridge while I'm waiting for
the other offers to come through and
going to Bob's great axes. He's the best
guy in uh Runescape for this, but
obviously if you have a house with an
armor stand in it, that is more ideal.
Uh where the is Bob? There we go.
Uh so we're just going to repair this
krill's item. It's going to cost 60k to
repair and we spent about 300k on it.
Uh, so we'll have to go have a quick
look and see how profitable that is
going to be. Uh, if we head back to the
Grand
Exchange. Oh, what? Okay, looks like we
bought another Verac Helm Zero.
Interesting. Okay, well, I'll put
another offer in for those. That's very
odd that those all came through at once.
But anyway, 360 is what we 365 is what
we spent on them in total. And uh, we
can sell this for and we sell it for
about 415. That is about 50k in profit.
Really easy to do. Not very risky at
all. You either buy the item and you
profit or you just don't buy it. It's
not that big a deal. And we're going to
be selling this off for 415. And I'll
have to go ahead and repair the other
one. All right, we're repairing the
other one for
60k. Thank you very much. All right,
we'll head back to the Grand Exchange
and maybe we'll have another magical
offer come through. Okay, just a few
seconds later, the actual uh full set
came through. That is going to be a
Zamarak or an unholy book page set.
There we go. And if we go ahead and sell
it back on the Grand Exchange, we'll
calculate how much we're going to make
on each one of these sets. All right,
we're going to make 100k still if we
sell it for the low price. And I think
that's probably more likely to sell in
the well 10 minutes pretty well that I
have left. Uh so one we're going to sell
for 1712. We sold the Verox Helm for
415. Perfect. Um, I think we're going to
pull this out and we'll maybe give this
a few seconds. If that doesn't come
through, I might just wait this last 10
minutes out and just try to sell the
stuff I have instead of dumping it back
and potentially losing some money. Okay,
so I've sold off the Verox Helm for
another 50k in profit. And I only have
10 minutes left, so I think I'm going to
pull out all the offers except for the
page three just in the hopes that we can
get at least one more of those. And pull
that out. And pull that out. Uh, it's
going to take a little while for these
to sell. I think two might be pushing it
anyway, but uh yeah, we'll hope to buy
at least one more of these pages and
then we'll fully cancel everything.
Okay, so Zamrack page three came through
and uh I think I'll just cancel out now.
No point keeping it in there any longer.
Perfect. And we're going to do the last
set combination here. And that will
probably be it for the episode. So,
let's go ahead and pop this in here for
1712. And well, let's put a little
lower. And hopefully we can sell at
least one of these before the eight
minutes is up. Okay, so let's pull these
two out because clearly they're not
going to sell. And we'll just dump them
and see how much money I hopefully still
make and not lose. Uh so I was hoping to
sell them for
175 and they're actually going to sell
for
uh 1699. That's not too bad actually. Uh
and there we go. So that's about it,
guys. 20 seconds left. Let's just cancel
that off. uh sell off everything in our
inventory just for the maximum value or
at least these two
anyway. Okay, so let's go ahead and
price check our inventory and see how
much I made off of just a couple flips
honestly and all set combinations. So we
started with 50 mil and I'm ending at
51.9. So 2 mil in profit pretty well in
1 hour. Set combinations are the way to
go, I'm telling you. uh so many
profitable ways to flip and uh it's all
very quick. As you can see, all this was
done in just one hour and uh you don't
really actually need this much money to
start with. You can do one set at a time
and sell them back and just kind of
rotate through. It's a little slower uh
but still extremely good. So anyway, I
hope you guys enjoyed the video and I'll
see you guys in the next one.
[Music]
Yeah. Heat.